for two weeks the greek island of zanti
with its crystal clear waters
provided the perfect escape for
stephanie whitfield and her husband
then came the flight home to cardiff on
tuesday
there wasn't much social distancing and
people didn't seem to be very well
educated in the use of wearing masks
we had people wearing it underneath
their noses underneath their chins
and people taking the mask off to talk
to other people
in fact they were so worried they'd
already decided to self-isolate
even before news emerged that 16
passengers on tui flight 6215
had tested positive for covid seven were
thought to be potentially infectious
while on the plane
tui says it's concerned to hear about
mrs whitfield's claims
and a full investigation is underway
making it clear that passengers are
informed both before
and during the flight of the need to
wear masks
except when eating and drinking now
there are questions about how long it's
taking health officials
to contact the 193 people on board
to tell them to self-isolate if ever
there was a case study
for why arrival testing at airports
needs to be introduced as soon as
possible
then this tui flight is it they could
have captured everybody coming off the
flight
immediately tested them then ask them to
quarantine for five days
and then do a second test and if that
process had been carried out
as other countries are doing then they
would have been able to contact
everybody straight away
many airlines have been strictly
enforcing the rules
but there's concern about whether those
rules are up to the job
if for say over 95 percent of the flight
time
everyone wore the mask properly then it
would be
some degree of additional protection
afforded to all the passengers and the
crew
on that airline on the other hand
if they are only wearing the mask for
about say
50 or less during the flight
then actually on a full flight it is
only
very symbolic and nobody is being
protected
in that case about 30 people returning
to wales from different parts of zante
on different planes have tested positive
for the virus in the past week
it's hard to tell when the passengers on
tuesday's flight were infected
now stephanie has developed a mild cough
and sore throat
she and her husband will be tested on
tuesday to see if they should be added
to that list
emma birchley sky news